ó muito bom dia meu nome é ficar por aí
ricardo cintra nós somos nós nunca
fizemos clima em que a nossa vida todos
a neurose que já foi miss nós temos
passado alarga as coisas também
aliás nós quisemos sempre trabalhar com
pessoas normais e então grande idéia que
nós tivemos fomos para as organizações
que encontrar as coisas fantásticas lá
para questões nas empresas têm
completamente interessantes mas é como
um antigo antibiótico de largo espectro
ou seja nós encontramos espaço público
absorve quase tudo hoje em dia que está
a conduzir equipes usando muitos três
salas muito pior palavras muito presto
muito milho pode passar aquilo que vai
acontecer a seguir e aquilo que nós
seguíamos há algum tempo atrás e
continuasse valendo hoje e ajudar
empresas a atingir resultados
é verdade a nossa missão mas ajudar a
atingir resultados com pessoas
primeiro as pessoas felizes suas
autênticas portuguesa que o que acontece
é que esses filmes disse ontem que os
homens estão lá do corpo como não estão
de alma e já agora pessoas inspiradas em
conceitos inspiração entre tantas
pessoas consigam fazer coisas diferentes
coisas inovadoras têm é importante dizer
mas hoje em dia com este contexto do vau
crise de atenção obsessiva resultados a
opção para o assunto custo cada vez mais
decisões muito sérias
portanto trabalhar e um riso ea
capacidade ou incapacidade nos livros
sobre nós próprios estima ambicione de
que estamos a falar com você pode
começar primeiro falar sobre o rio
importância do rio
livre estamos a fazer uma manifestação
complementá lo
o que eu quero dizer com isto nós
fazendo rááá já pararam e seis por aqui
né e praticamente está em um conjunto de
gestos a um som e instrumentos pressão
seguida várias inspirações como é que
vencer padronizada é que estão os
coloque e mas porque que nós nos livros
qual é a função mesmo do rio
há várias teorias que tentam explicar
tudo isto uma delas tem a ver com nós
rimos para nos sentirmos melhor e tenta
dar resposta porque é que nós nos vimos
do infortúnio dos outros óleos usados
hoje por exemplo o mel e olha a maioria
tropeçou e caiu total é este túnel e
isso parece que eu estou a tentar sentir
melhor por confiar uma pessoa que ir no
fundo é uma forma de eu sinto melhor em
comparação com os outros
é uma forma de pensar e teoria da
superioridade existe uma outra teoria
que é querido é um livro emocional é uma
teoria de origem fabiana love sex magic
não teve só por lívio sexual também há
várias formas nós temos nos aliviar
emocionalmente e é uma voz que quando
estou muito nervoso quando eu estou
muito muito muito tenso no que vai
acontecer em situações de valorização da
sua vontade enquanto lá da dbm irene que
não conseguem não conseguem parar
é impressionante e é emocionante eu
tenho tanta emoção caso entre tantas
coisas aqui que fazer reforma eo love
prestou libertar para para o mundo a uma
terceira teoria que embora no fundo é
porque nós nos livros das piadas só
porque conseguimos determinadas
mensagens que seria incongruente
basicamente é quando uma determinada
mensagem tem um contexto e depois aquilo
que aconteceu a seguir que é um dos fãs
que é completamente enfrentou em extrato
do contrato inicial o que significa que
uma linda surpresa em si mas como se
gerasse uma aprendizagem
então vamos ver o risco em várias
funções o vi bem estar à procura do
homem está livre da ação ou de
aprendizagem mas em qualquer uma vela
sorriso pode ter uma função social muito
importante e vai ter essa função social
em função de uma variável
isso vê-se forçado o sorriso e facto
autêntico olha lá por exemplo foi
tranquilo
três senhoras ficar por aí eu estava a
fazer era um país em que o que vocês
acham tatá eu sou responsável aos risos
nem de instituições 1 2 e 3 0
também é lá mas provavelmente todos
concordamos que não há um sorriso se
quiserem mas vamos pensar com as um
esboço do riso que é forçado todos nós
num normais temos aqui uma capacidade
interessantes para conseguir identificar
com os outros e às vezes nós próprios
quando é que estou a ser genuína só
quando estou rindo genuinamente
mecanismo interno que nós temos é
fundamental para nós conseguimos
tentamos ser relações com os outros não
significa que a faz rir com os outros é
uma espécie de uma cola social é algo
que nós podemos utilizar para criar
relações e condições positivas longo
prazo
agora aqui um problema associado é esta
a cola é que vive num elemento é alto
nós dificilmente conseguimos controlar
ou ativarem tentou investigar um tão
ativa quanto queremos expandir agora
imagine um elemento para mim força lá em
cima também não ficou sentindo mas
pareceu ele é fantástico foi criar a
ilusão é fantástico para nós estarmos
bem uns com os outros mas não é
automático o que é curioso é que têm
sido feitas muitas experiências muita
investigação para tentar perceber como é
que surge é genuinamente conclusão
quando existe um contexto do viso existe
30 vezes maior probabilidade de as
pessoas saírem de uma determinada piada
da situação ruim
este é o primeiro bom ou o uhuu vai
insistir insistir espírito é delicioso
vai jogar a ave incrível negócio
agora vou esperar e ver se vão pedir
preto pra entrar no regime mas ao mesmo
tempo vamos abrir este segundo sombra o
favor
o facto há estudos que mostram que ir em
todas as séries cômicas e tudo o que se
contém as faixas de gargalhar a correr
porque aumenta a probabilidade de as
pessoas rirem mas ainda isto demonstra o
mesmo interesse das piadas pessoas basta
encontrar alguém confirmou lado e que
esteja rir nós olhamos nos olhos em
função do rio
inscreva se sentir melhor por libertar
seja o que for mas é o efeito do riso em
nós é uma coisa incrível não só em nós
próprios que há quem diga e facto há
muito trabalho que demonstra que o riso
até melhor o próprio sistema imunitário
mas a relação com os crimes que vão ser
com os outros melhora significativamente
agora eu disse que eu vejo problema é
que eles saibam para nos casos mas nós
queríamos descaro um tempo específico
risco de ver com a capacidade em que
precisar nós nos rirmos sobre nós
próprios devam sim mas quando nós nos
rimos sobre nós próprios que a
capacidade ou incapacidade pode ajudar
mas uma outra coisa que nós conseguimos
lidar com algumas funções podemos
teremos presenças mais negativas como
por exemplo a a a raiva ou por exemplo a
cobra o mesmo resultado da frustração
por exemplo eu trabalhei no táxi para 42
boa e pinha que apanhará 5 para cascais
durante dois anos eu fiz este percurso
ea uma altura em que eu vou numa faixa e
aparece uma placa a dizer assim eu tenho
como estar a vir aí eu fui lá transitam
aí tem que estar à direita e que lessem
tiridá prefiro essa ideia porque se
empatar a estrada e o que acontece nós
conseguimos ver perfeitamente a mãe
apresenta por trânsito pára arranca por
que é que eu faço com um bom condutor eo
estigma direita evoluindo para que até
que chega mesmo e uma das coisas que
milita brutalmente a mulher e evitava
era um chico esperto eram as pessoas que
eu ia
aquelas suas em que o volume para rende
precisando de abertura na oportunidade
então em caixa e uma vez ou outra eu
sentia indignado injustiçado mas é coisa
e agora para em dois anos eu vá com isto
numa altura em que era um desporto
matinal e os vinham já tava olhar no
retrovisor e hoje quero tudo em 13
depois que estava irritado mesmo que eu
entrava dois carros da frente ficaram
encantados com o amigo tinha deixava
entrar para história do tal maneira em
um estranho pra mim tal maneira que o
chico me deixava o trabalho editado na
guarda até que um momento curioso do
estudo foi um dia que eu cheguei em casa
atrasado e eu tenho um diretor eu ia
fazer uma apresentação e pineto voar
direto ao principal nunca era diretor
geral regista 96 que atrasará o mau
espírito incrível o que é que eu faço
que se em todos os meus princípios e
cheguei olha a rodovia não soube acabar
e lá fui
e não é que o tentar entrar para este
gente sinceramente o primeiro que foi
segundo na vida deles quando deixarem
entrar em vigor o rio ave não sou
espaçoso balé
aí é que vai perder o envio fazer o
mesmo e portanto ainda não vê é não
deixar não deixar entrar e eu pensei o
que de facto diz moshe esperto em
potencial não significa hoje em dia a
queda foi mais um grande continuar já
que não deve ser só mais um grande tacho
de centrar as vezes de sentar num bar 2
a 3 dentro do apartamento
qualquer das formas esta capacidade ou
incapacidade para nos deixar entrar os
de instituições olhar uns para elas e
aprendemos com os irmãos nós da figura
totais com 200 instituições é
fundamental para conseguir fazer uma
coisa que não deixar que algumas
emissões menos positivas transforma em
comportamentos de risco e que a gente
grande é complicado é fazer com que os
gente nós fazemos não só isso mas não é
que agora pode ter consequências
parei há muitas vezes aqui o que
acontece é que esta incapacidade pode
destruir relações ou pode manter mansões
no vaso versatilidade ou com pouca
qualidade por exemplo vamos comer uma
semana um fiat uno branco melhor imagine
esta situação
imagine temos uma empresa eu sou chefe e
aqui o ricardo é uma curva pode ser
combinado
agora imagine que ontem pedi lhe para eu
fazer um relatório conclui que disse e
que eu tenho até as tampas para terminar
o vitória terminou está cheio de dúvidas
o que eu vou fazer hoje e eu como chefe
que só vou acompanhar o trabalho de los
angeles vai fazer uma sessão cantinho já
ouviram falar nisto agora tá muito
embora já tem um cantinho então dinheiro
eu vou cantar o seu desempenho e senta
lá está chegando e vamos fazer o que o
time faça em breve garante gosto é
confortável em trabalhar terminou que
entre 100 e 150 então tá tudo certo não
fez praticamente não tenho que o uso do
vídeo show vai ter mais dúvidas que
turquia mesmo preciso tocar para ouvir
as missões que virão os provedores
portanto você fez o time se classifique
da paz de 2011 disse ele que chega pelo
ministro mas nani resolveu não posso
falar assim olhando agora certo tá sim é
também falar de minha parte que o placar
isso já era aqui na página 12 e sem ir à
fifa a união hoje que horas
temos as nossas não esqueça as de nova
york a cantora estava em tamanho quanto
vai continuar a correr há dúvida de que
lá aqui página 12
sim mas não vê se pode ter aqui o clipe
mostra portavam sem fatores só deu um
toquinho tá tudo quem acompanhava não
superou acompanhando seja obrigado olhe
lá
obrigado muitas vezes o que acontece é
que se perguntarem este fim se a
companhia sustos o que vocês acham que o
chefe em várias vezes
aliás op 61 chefe me acompanhou a
campanha super super acompanhando isso
lançou o espetáculo é fantástico mas
vocês acham que isso aconteça nas
empresas deste tipo letal
acontece também fora das empresas
sim vamos imaginar sábado final do via é
a coisa mais linda vidas consumiram e
dizer 'sim cristo tem o que falar com os
filhos porque algum problema
ah eu já não tenha paciência e cultural
de todos porque a inadimplência é normal
não vai rolar por favor um tamanho
então normalmente o pai vai então tás em
taipa
olha é tua mãe disse que falar contigo
algum problema passa alguma coisa que eu
tenho tá tá bonito x maria joão só abre
agora volta pagas mas algum problema
posso chegar à tua mãe tá tudo em ordem
tá certeza absoluta ninja também ia
temos que fazer isso mais vezes é
conversar é que entendemos criados por
da grande
felizmente que só aconteça em países
longínquos
é curioso que algumas dessas situações
acontecem também em contexto
organizacional
então existem em algumas organizações
mais uma vez afastado é que a nossa zona
um conjunto de vídeos que os índios
cinzento
podemos olhar e podemos perceber logo
que estão normalmente têm uma postura
assim e o olho esquerdo ligeiramente
chave
normalmente eu sempre olhar por cima
para baixo e tem um movimento realmente
que tinha visto aquilo que um dia já
visto que o chão fazer outra vez
custará mais um corte em cima do nome
mariana
além dos recursos humanos vão comprar
outra vez carlos quem trabalha aqui p p
não pode ser assim mas há 20 anos aqui
meu normais são todas as normais de cima
e de cima tudo normal
é impressionante normalmente não ficam
por aqui
apesar de todas estas funções e rirem
que não que desce para os fracos
então normalmente chegam a casa com
estou cinzento muito carregado e vamos
imaginar que sua coisa mais linda quando
chegar a casa deveria produzir um jantar
daqui os fabulosos para que os momentos
de rara beleza que podem existir já com
relações de 20 anos é o dia caem é o dia
porque não marcaria estávamos na mesma
coisa mais linda mas o jantar já
passamos a partir da entrada estamos eua
e então eu viesse pra ela
assim não faz momento minha com barba
então o que acontece
estamos nos ajeitar eo nosso então vira
uma coisa mais linda e diz incrível nem
sabe o que aconteceu hoje através de
coisa mais linda pensar não acredito por
favor não vai falar outra vez dos
normais mais uma vez continua a
trabalhar com normais sabe o que
conseguimos fazer agora querida o que
vão fazer neste momento é cortar a tvs
ou cortar através já visto que vai
acontecendo e vão comprar carro novo e
eu então e então também com essa cara
porque eu nunca ouvi 20 anos dois com um
conjunto de emoções é que o farto ela aí
hoje em dia
achavam que era uma questão normal é
isso você dar uma maneirada enxergou
muito bem preparada para qualquer outro
estou farta crise mas porque quer se faz
tão forte no primeiro ano de casamento
que pensei que fosse encerrada capita
nos pesados e tu falas muitos anormais
que trabalhos no segundo ano fui
investimento nos filho o que eu pensei
tá ansioso por causa do filho o que
aconteceu
continua colecionando anormais 3º 4º 5º
ano tenha se mano dias e um ano 20 mães
na realidade estamos a falar de um tema
é rir de nós próprios
na verdade é que este centro oeste a
primeira é essa capacidade
porém essa capacidade provavelmente
porque já olham passou realizável com o
que sempre do que os negativos ou seja
provavelmente sou sim as que mais sofrem
este mundo
os vírus existe um super herói que tem
um dia muito complicado
estou a falar do seu génio humano não é
possível alcançar e abrir o olinda corra
mela e tem quatro a mais ínfima para o
metal eo estraçalhar não é possível eu
normalmente nunca sai pela porta vai ser
pela janela e então não há porque não
moço é nada de boninho
vejam este via vai provocar vai ter um
carro santo aston martin normalmente mas
vai entrar um conjunto dos peões e lá
foi o carro ainda não há um soul e
problemas de gestão o que em movimento
mesmo bastante água e todos os golfinhos
e aquelas coisas todas vêm atrás deu e
um dia complicado início então imaginem
no final do dia no grupo 5
eu sai de água abaixo
impecável
uma flor em sua ilha paradisíaca tem uma
vivenda enorme em quem está à sua espera
quantas lado esquerdo
a loura do lado direito a morena no meio
vocês quiserem
a mãe então normalmente elas vêm sempre
com ar daquela forma eu treinar também
na próxima vai semear o assunto em
monchique está incrível desse esporte
standard que não entra na cabeça de
ninguém
vocês viram como foi homofobia yuko vai
inspirar a janela já estava com quatro a
mais em cima e hoje ritchie criaram um
negócio marketing que faz isso para mim
não é fácil porque eu tenho qualidade de
serviço em tudo o que faz
como mensagem final
minha senhora de mais dinheiro existe
técnica do james bond james bond quando
chega de só mãe nenhum dos bons
james collins estivemos aqui o dias
invento é fácil cuidar desta técnica da
senhora acha que os senhores e só espera
casa e dizer o nome é porém ricardo
procurar e ia festa começa
ó ó